do you actually believe we have proof
that aliens exist
now we have intriguing
uh evidence that leads us to the
possibility that we might have found or
that objects from produced by other
technological civilizations arrived near
Earth there is some intriguing evidence
uh but wait
for our analysis of what we found in the
Pacific Ocean wait for more data to be
collected before we all say we have the
proof it's possible the US government
has materials or information that is
relevant but it's classified I don't
have access to it so what you see is
what you get when you speak with me I'm
not hiding anything I'm telling you
exactly the situation
with the US government we don't know
do you uh do you uh can you at all
speculate to say you think if I was to
speculate I would say aliens do exist or
not oh yeah definitely I think it's
arrogant of us to believe that we are uh
the most intelligent species that ever
lived since the big bang that Albert
Einstein was the smartest scientist who
lived for the past 13.8 billion years
that's completely ridiculous actually
because you have tens of billions of
stars like the sun most of them formed
billions of years before the Sun so you
know if you just roll the dice of
technological civil it's very likely
that you had many more in our past many
of those died those civilizations are
not around anymore there were tragedies
you know the sun in a billion years
forget about global warming you know the
situation here in Florida is getting
warm and warm forget about what we do to
our planet in a billion years the sun
will boil off all the oceans on Earth
and other stars that formed more than a
billion years ago before the sun already
went through that so just think about an
Earth-like planet near one of these
stars that you know be a billion years
ago went through that and there must
have been a mass Exodus of you know uh
and
people out there or things like
creatures out there trying to leave the
planet you know people like Elon Musk
would make much more money because
everyone would want to go on a spaceship
and leave the planet it was the biggest
item in the news that the star is about
to extinct life on their Planet you know
the situation is like Mars Mars became a
desert once it lost its liquid water and
Ocean and the atmosphere so the same may
happen to Earth in a billion years and
what I'm saying is there were tragedies
in Cosmic history is a lot of
civilizations perished we are not aware
of that because we just came a few
million years ago we started looking at
the sky just over the past few centuries
you know a methodical way so you know we
are like an infant not aware of the
bigger perspective and we behave
irresponsibly because we don't really
try to seek that data so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign